Hello everyone,
let's look at a quick demo of our NTL
tool.
Lead generation is a significant task for
our leasing business brokers,
often involving extensive time spent
scrolling through online news feeds to
identify potential leads.
Our NTL tool streamlines this process by
automating the search and analysis of the
latest news.
It employs cutting edge generative AI and
state-of-the-art LLMS to go through
information efficiently.
It displays a curated list of potential
leads directly to our brokers,
thus significantly saving time and
enhancing their productivity.
Currently for this task,
Alphasense is a license tool being used
by our research teams in US.
But there is a catch here.
Alphasense requires a lot of post
processing efforts to Polish the results
in a way which is useful to our brokers.
NTL eliminates all this.
It doesn't require any post processing
and it doesn't require any licensing
costs also.
Now let's see a quick working demo of
this NTL tool.
Now let's see how our tool operates.
First you will encounter a drop down menu.
Here you have the option to choose a
single client or multiple clients
simultaneously or OP to fetch data for
all the clients.
For this demo purpose,
I will select single or multiple clients.
Next,
you can specify the type of news you are
interested in.
For instance,
we will select expansion for our demo.
If necessary,
you can also mention other types if you
want to.
And also,
let's say we are focusing on a specific
client,
which happens to be JPMorgan in our case.
Now you can select in a date range for
news analysis.
I'll put it from 1st of this month to
20th.
Once you have set all the parameters,
the tool will take a few seconds to
process the information and generate the
results.
As you can see,
it is already connected to Google News
and it is processing the news now.
Once the processing is done,
as you can observe,
the final results are organized in a
table format which can also be
conveniently downloaded as a spreadsheet.
Coming to the future road map of this
project,
we plan to automatically identify the
sector which the news belongs to.
We also plan to integrate this to our
existing CRM systems and we can also
periodically push out all these leads on
a predator mined frequency.
Hope this provides you with an overview
of the capabilities of our tool.
Thank you for your time and attention.